hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on foreign again so
we're gonna be looking at the year for
season one battle past could be a
hundred tears full of bunch of stuff
paid stuff free stuff we're gonna look
through all that stuff today today we're
gonna be getting in this season
obviously if you don't get it this
season you won't be able to get it for
next season so definitely make sure to
get this as fast as possible already I'm
seeing a lot of different signatures
here we get in a bunch of stuff it looks
like we have a Shema stone for the Wulin
they kind of go into this green color we
then have left fields fate I'm not gonna
bother pronouncing it go to more of this
silver kind of snowy tone we have this
one for the samurai we're gonna use are
moochers an example in the golden
version not too [ __ ] bad actually I
do
I'd actually don't mind that and we go
to the Raider you know the Vikings
they're gonna be covered in I believe a
black coat already saw this a second ago
before I started the video oh yeah this
is actually not too bad this is the very
first thing you get and it's a signature
for every single character so definitely
pick that up what do we got we got a
symbol not too bad we got the very first
outline we're gonna be picking up kind
of reminds me of one of the other
outlines we have before we got add too
we have the warden weapon set so if
you're a warden player you get it very
very quickly then we get a symbol that's
going to be going on all the characters
shields emblem wherever the hell you
want to put the symbol it's going to be
all over the character it's gonna be the
truce of wyvern Dale - then there's the
execution we have the tale of hybrid
execution forepeak a little neck snap
there but I believe it this is an effect
this isn't an actual execution so this
is the dragon kind of going around not
too bad we have a color then a Tier four
yeah this is tier four we have a color
not too bad you know this is for the
samurai so if we keep that in mind we
got some steel going into this one XP
boost a Orochi paint pattern out of this
sorry this is for the samurai but this
is a row she's not too bad I feel like
this would look a lot better if I didn't
have the default colors but and that's
who bad Ken today's weapon is at 7 it's
not a bad looking weapon honestly got
some salvage got the execution effect
for the Vikings I believe this is
probably the same thing as we just saw
yeah this is gonna be the same thing so
now the Vikings can get it at tier 9 we
have then paint patterns
for the nights we then have a what looks
like to be a symbol for the samurai
Raiders getting his weapon at tier
eleven not too bad
steel at 300 steel at tier 12 three days
of champion status at 13
we got the neutral color palette for the
rule in it looks like it's got like a
red white green kind of thing nothing
crazy but I actually don't mind this
color then we got the execution effect
we've already seen it but this is gonna
be it's here 14 T on DS getting his
weapon at 15 with PKS getting hers at 18
we have a simple emblem going on for the
Knights got some salvaged some XP boosts
the execution effect now for the ruling
and then we also have the color palette
for the Vikings at tier 19 what else we
got Hiroshi's is at 21 his wyvern dale
prodigy set got some steel got some
paint patterns that we've seen before
then we have some XP boosts true supply
burned Dale lookin symbols for the Wulin
not too bad actually doesn't actually I
feel like that could fit with a lot of
characters this little flower in the
middle there then we have the scavenger
crate already a quarter of the way
through we haven't embossing the might
of wyvern oh right there on T on Dee's
chest not too bad I don't really see
myself using it that often but I think
it'd be pretty cool mr. Kerr gets the
weapon at tier 25 then we have salvage
at a hundred new shoes weapon at 27 the
emblem again we've already seen we have
a new battle outfit called B Herald of Y
burn Dale this is once again going to be
for the Vikings this time so this will
be only for the Vikings that other ones
are probably become a lot later not too
bad though I feel like the color palette
in general won't really fit with my
character but it works we have the
regalia of wyvern Dale this is for all
the vikings as well so it looks like
it's going to be faction based so it all
be the same so it's why not you're a
Viking guy typical pick that up at 30 XP
boost more paint patterns the color now
for the Knights lob ringers weapon at 32
not too bad of a looking weapon if I do
say so myself
300 steel and now the ruling are getting
the battle outfits with the accompanying
regalia ornaments so pretty cool
actually I don't mind that ornament I
think that's a lot better than the
Vikings got not too bad
then we have a 39 as gonna be you're
seeing a theme here at 39
it's the same thing but now with the
samurai with their regalia Valkyries
getting her weapon at 38 Naboo she's at
35 with some symbols some steel some
Salvage all the juicy stuff there 42
shaolin's getting his bonk stick and
then the Knights at 44 get their
finishing touches for the battle outfit
and the ornaments so not too shabby
there what else do we got we got the
paint pattern and got some other stuff
very very basic things and now it's just
all the factions trying to catch up with
one another 45 we got some steel their
scavenger crates conks getting his
weapon at 46 pretty juicy there and then
we got at 47 got some salvage all that
beautiful stuff as usual nothing too
wild this coming out yet but I believe
at 54 as I'm seeing here I'm gonna get
some nice stuff going should go keys
here
51 his weapon set XP boost the colors
you name it getting an era Musha Idol so
this is for the samurai very an idol
effect this is going to be for the
dragon once again still kind of confused
why there's a dragon maybe that's just
me not too bad though so this is gonna
be for all samurai I'm gonna be the same
Idol effect 59 is gonna be the same
thing before the Vikings we're gonna
have to show it again
JJ's getting his weapon at 58 with
warlord players at 55 with very similar
stuff of the embossing and the paint
patterns and the steel that we've been
seeing for pretty much the whole pass at
the moment Centurions weapon at 61 the
Knights now get the effect at 64 with
more paint patterns as well and some
steel and some Salvage the usual bits
shinobi at 66 and then it finishes off
with the woolen at 69 nice getting the
effect there we got some steel got some
salvage as usual going over to 70 we
have 71 for gladiator 73 for Highlander
and then no more paint patterns and
other stuff like that some more
conquered to fit you know the conch
defender color for the Knights some cool
stuff like that
our Musha weapon at 76 more of the
embossing 'he's the Roulin now get an
emo defect which is probably once again
with the dragon at 79 that's what I'm
guessing perfect that's pretty cool so
you'll be getting that later Vikings at
84 with the same effect shaman gets her
weapon set very very deep into the bat
pass at 81 with a hundred steel being
over there for the free pass
the samurai get theirs at 89 heat so
kiri gets her weapon at 89 BP's gets her
his weapon at 85 I'm trying to knots I'm
going a little bit fast I apologize here
he took carries weapon obviously super
super big and then BP's weapon over here
at 85 for sure more a lot of salvage in
this section going on to the last 10 we
have yours at 91 with finishing off the
Knights emo defect pretty cool with the
dragon of course we got the defender
colors got some steel got some more
symbols going to 94 95 and 96 we have
soon Dazs new weapon really nice black
look to it definitely [ __ ] with that
weapon and then of course some more
symbols some scavenger crates the juicy
bits now we're getting to what looks
like executions real quick I just want
to show off the outline that's actually
not too bad now we have the Knights this
is okay so this is these are faction
based meaning the Vikings will have a
different one to the Knights but it's
not hero based okay we got claw claw
rent which is a little weapon for peek
which is a weapon for all the characters
somehow I don't know where this comes
out of but some Giants or comes up right
to the stomach right to the stomach
again decapitation over it's the same
animation for all of the bike are all
been Knights here we have I'm not gonna
be able to pronounce that name another
weapon comes up out of nowhere but it's
more of a samurai esque weapon we'll cut
to the stomach and a decapitation right
away real quick and clean really cool
actually it seems like yeah they
definitely just take the weapon that's
part of it they don't just grab their
weapons that's not too bad for the
Vikings we have more names I can't
pronounce this comes up out of the black
mist a little cuts the stomach off off
of that are completely leg sweeps in and
then just oh they're still going oh my
goodness goddamn yes is real cool I'm
definitely [ __ ] with these executions
I like that it's at least faction based
and not you know everyone gets the same
exact thing it makes it a little bit
more unique obviously everybody would
like to have individual ones but that
would just take forever
we got goes on you know I think a little
pink sword
okay my slash that's the Asha actually
kind of reminds me a lot of what's he on
D would do same thing we got with
Shaolin blade comes up I don't over with
the feathers two cuts and they're down
personally got us a Vikings got the best
one I don't know maybe the [ __ ] I
don't know foe probably the Knights got
like the least favorite in my opinion
bullying are pretty cool yeah and then
we got seven days of champion status
embossing for the Knights and of course
the fought off we have the outline I've
been rambling a bit I do apologize I was
just trying to cover everything of
course you could see this all for
yourself the battle pass ends in 83 days
so you have about two months in about
two weeks to get everything in this pass
of course you could purchase the pass
for $10 us and then you can also get
tears with all of this stuff here I plan
on buying a big majority of the pass
because I have this deal for it yeah you
guys like anything in the past you like
those executions that we let me know in
the comments below
I got sticker girls today peace out I'll
see you for the stream in a bit thank
for coming by
[Music]
[Music]
you